cinco semanas el tiempo que toma
convertirse en soldado en el pueblo
Sureño inglés de durrington cerca de
stonehenge hasta ucranianos han cambiado
sus ropas civiles por el uniforme con su
tierra natal bajo asedio han decidido
tomar las armas y dar pelea a los rusos
antes de que comenzara la invasión yo
era solo un ingeniero y luego después de
que empezó no pude seguir siéndolo no
pude seguir viviendo la vida de civil
así que me uní a las filas de las
fuerzas armadas ucranianas
aquí reciben un Rango de entrenamiento
que incluye táctica cuidados médicos y
hasta asesorías psicológica durante la
educación militar intensiva los futuros
soldados también aprenden las reglas de
la guerra
las dos destrezas más importantes que
necesitamos enseñarles en este
adiestramiento son como sobrevivir en el
campo de batalla y Cómo ser lo más
letales posible en una lucha cercana
para eso los llevamos por un programa de
entrenamiento integral donde los temas
clave son puntería y manejo de armas
guerrilla urbana guerra de trincheras
primeros auxilios en el campo de batalla
y la importancia de las leyes en el
conflicto armado
para estos civiles la prueba en el campo
de batalla se acerca rápidamente los
oficiales británicos se dicen que han
modificado métodos de entrenamiento para
crear un abordaje más ofensivo De modo
que los ucranianos no solo se defiendan
sino que logran recuperar terreno con
esto presente Los Nuevos soldados
esperan continuar la contraofensiva que
ha sido tan exitosa para kiev en las
últimas semanas